tian tu es tout de suite c'est la
deuxième partie de votre émission
politique la voix est libre présentée
par ligne au mali merci pauline deuxième
partie de la voie est libre
effectivement avec andré accary
président du conseil départemental de
saône et loire delphine fleury marie
laure capitain et hamid el hassouni on
continue sur ce dont on parle est tout à
leur signification politique forte
présence du front national a ni des
nations unies que vous vous étiez en
triangulaire mais la présence du front
national sur votre canton dont on
parlait précédemment elle était
particulière aussi bien sur le front
national s'est octroyé une place de
choix dans le paysage politique que
français je dire le temps du bipartisme
est révolu c'est un principe de réalité
après la question qui se pose est de
savoir si les électeurs adhèrent aux
idées du fn ou expriment un cri de
colère pour moi j'espère de tout coeur
que c'est quand même une parenthèse et
qu' il n'y a pas réellement d'adhésion
aux idées du front national parce que
depuis 2007 qu'est ce qu'on constate on
constate tout simplement la lepénisation
des esprits est que des sujets
récurrents qui reviennent à la une de
l'actualité notamment sur l'immigration
la sécurité
l'exemple de la cantine à chalon sur
saône doubs réalisé pour un noël j'en
profite aussi pour mettre en garde de la
droite dite républicaine qui fait de la
surenchère de la course à l'échalote en
disant je vais essayer d'aller marcher
sur les plates-bandes du front national
mais je dis simplement que les électeurs
préfèrent l'original à la copie
donc je pense que la droite devrait y
réfléchir à deux fois j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui et les digues se fissure
que ce mur qui séparait la droite de
l'extrême droite a tendance à à se
fissurer
mais il ya aussi par rapport au front
national c'est une réalité je pense que
c'est un message adressé au gouvernement
je pense que les réformes qui sont en
cours devrait permettre au pays de se
redresser peut-être que na n'ont pas
suffisamment trop loin je pense qu'il
faut accélérer et que les français
attendent des résultats au niveau du
chômage et tout pouvoir d'achat et le
troisième point concernant évidemment
ces élections départementales c'est le
fait que les élections intermédiaires
depuis la création de la vème république
sont toujours défavorables au pouvoir en
place et que là cette année on n'a pas
dérogé à la règle simplement ça fait
longtemps que ça dure andré accary vous
avez pensé quoi où quand il ya eu
effectivement vous vous aviez le
décompte de poux waucampt pondre ce
département dans son ensemble avec vos
binôme qui n'étaient pas tous vous
disiez issus de l'ump les gens la
société civile il ya des gens du pays
quand il ya eu cette polémique
spécifique sur chalon avec le maire de
chalon cas des annonces et supprimait
les menus de substitution propositions
reprises par nicolas sarkozy au niveau
national
beaucoup l'ont analysée comme la volonté
de pouvoir récupérer les électeurs
pourront l'un d'avoir une porosité plus
fort contre électeur du front national
et candidat de droite vous vous êtes dit
quoi vous c'est une bonne idée on va
récupérer des voix au deuxième tour où
vous vous êtes dit ça va compliquer
l'ensemble de mes candidats de droite et
leur vie en commun objectivement oui
pour moi ça ne change rien parce que
j'ai basé toute la campagne électorale
sur une vraie au fait des propositions
des terrains des gouttes et je pense que
tant qu'on va
porter ce type d' analyse c'est à dire
on n'écoute pas la population
effectivement non on continuera à voir
une progression du front national moi je
pense que l'otan mathématiquement
pardonnez-moi sur l'écart entre les deux
cantons de chalon 2 et 3 l'électorat
front national au deuxième tour il
ressemble enfin il est beaucoup aller
sur les candidats de droite au deuxième
tour très manifestement écoutez
franchement les deux deux cantons
suscité de saône et loire n'a pas
comment c'était des cantons difficile
pour l'actuelle majorité arrive à faire
ça c'est clair un sénat pour commander
les quartiers difficiles mais tu en es
faut pas tout mélanger quand on a une
même sur des secteurs comme lumière une
vraie montée effectivement des voix du
front national je pense quand même à la
base il ya quand même un vrai problème
d' écoutes dont top ce gouvernement va
rester sourd et où il n'y aura pas de
vision pas de stratégie d aller retour
sans arrêt sur sur des effectivement des
compétences ou tout simplement des
décisions rien dessus je pense que il y
a
évidemment un ras-le-bol des électeurs
moi je les situent ses électeurs vous
savez qui vote pour des candidats
complètement obsolète sur le secteur
pulsions les a pas rencontrés les
candidats du front national je pense que
ça va au delà les parties est vous avez
effectivement des gens qui viennent sans
doute du front de gauche sans doute de
la gauche traditionnelle qui vaut aussi
pour pour ces candidats là parce que là
il y a je pense un réel problème d'
écoute et surtout de manque de résultats
donc je pense que c'est à un cri très
fort contre les partis politiques
traditionnels ça c'est sûr et a
ras-le-bol c'est évident et puis je vous
dis aussi contre un manque de résultats
vous avez envie de réagir et pour vous
faire rebondir certains d'entre eux vont
être suivi la soirée électorale chez
nous on a eu nicolas soret qui est élu
dionne qui est fait partie des rares
élus de gauche qui peut obtenir un peu
un siège dans l'yonne qui était très ému
dans cette soirée électorale en
racontant le contact qu'il avait avec
avec les gens et qui lui disaient ah non
mais il faut aller vite son expression
soirée c'était dare-dare fait quelque
chose dare-dare mais il parlait à sa
propre majorité n'est effectivement ça
on l'a vécu toullec en fait je dirais
même où l'on vit au quotidien enfin
l'élu qui n'est présent sur le terrain
que au moment des campagnes électorales
généralement il y pas il eut longtemps
voilà donc on le voit bien on le sent
bien une où on adressé des messages
effectivement fort au niveau 2 du
gouvernement leurs 10 ans
et tenez en compte essayez d'adressé
voilà je sais pas si c'est une
incompétence du gouvernement il faut pas
perdre de vue quand même qu'on vit dans
un monde qui est profondément en crise
il ya une crise économique financière
sociale une crise politique voilà c'est
crise là aussi qui donne ce résultat là
et c'est crise là elles sont pas menées
depuis 2012 elles
reviennent voilà vu que les effectifs
c'est une de bois ouais mais latente de
réponse il se fait extrêmement pressant
voilà donc là il faut qu'on ait des
réponses mais elles sont aussi
collective c'est nous à nos niveaux
aussi au conseil départemental qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir le mettre en place est
assez rapidement pour donner des signes
est plus que des signes peuvent dans la
nièvre et oui un territoire zéro chômeur
de longue durée avec atd quart monde
c'est un mets quelque chose de national
sur le secteur de prémery effectivement
on n'avait pas parlé et volontairement
pendant la campagne tout à fait voilà
pour pas que ce soit vécu comme une
annonce purement électoraliste c'est un
vrai un vrai engagement une un vrai
travail à faire oui oui donc on essaye
d'expérimenter mais dans les territoires
ruraux comme les nôtres on expérimente
tout le temps et sans arrêt si on ne
fait pas on s'en sort pas non plus donc
on l'a fait auparavant et continuera à
le faire et un mois justement ça l'était
acteurs ruraux marie laure capitain vous
les connaissez bien les conseils
départementaux
ils ont été d'ailleurs longtemps très
actif sortant sur les territoires ruraux
dans certains départements mais cette
crise cette montée du front national on
l'a beaucoup vu sur les territoires
ruraux il ya une vraie
incompréhension du monde une vraie
difficulté aussi pour les gens des
territoires ruraux le front national a
fait surtout une campagne sur des débats
nationaux la sécurité et l'emploi alors
que nous conseillers départementaux nous
sommes là pour apporter un mieux vivre
donc à nos concitoyens sur afin leurs
proches qui étaient faits par le front
national c'était de dire que la droite
s'évertuer
à comment à détruire la ruralité alors
là c'est vraiment scandaleux parce que
quand on voit ce qui a été fait sur le
département de l'yonne sur le dernier
mandat on a quand même injecté 5
millions et demi
d'investissement fin de subventions pour
aider les communes à investir nous avons
construit maison de retraite collège
cantine le centre aéré on s'est occupé
de la voirie donc voilà on est vraiment
proche de la population et je ne
comprends pas voilà ces attaques qui
n'ont qui n'ont aucun sens aucun sens
quand on vit vraiment à proximité des
gens sur les territoires ruraux il ya un
sentiment d'abandon très fort des
populations le recul des services
publics
fait que voilà ils se sentent abandonnés
un fermeture des bureaux de poste
notamment c'étaient des combats très
très rude par rapport à ce décalage
entre l'action et le ressenti parce que
sans donner des bons points ou des
mauvais points aux uns aux autres on
sait que le département de la nièvre
agit beaucoup avec toute une campagne
sur la ruralité justement pour autant il
ya des gens de votre majorité qui sont
les plus actifs sur ce sujet là dans
leur commune alors quand on est qui ont
été placés en grande difficulté je pense
à quelqu'un comme fabien bazin par
exemple sur un nouveau contre lui tout à
fait qu'il y avait été l'initiateur du
bouquet arabe qui a été qui est très
actif au niveau des nouvelles ruralités
très prudents les gens de s à ivan iv
l'ont pas forcément remercier de sa
belle en tout cas ils n'ont pas perçu
effectivement parce que encore une fois
c'est comment ça se traduit dans le
quotidien dans la vie de tous les jours
voilà donc etc il ya une difficulté de
sa de perception nous on voit bien que
ces avancées que effectivement il ya des
signes à des choses qui se mettent en
place et parfois faut laisser un peu de
temps aux choses mais concrètement dans
la vie des gens voilà c'est ça ne change
pas suffisamment vite parce que c'est
l'information qui est pas suffisamment
importante pour que la population
comprenne qu'on ait de la petite enfance
jusqu'à la fin de vie le conseil général
est là dans tous les secteurs finalement
ça pose la place du cours du conseil
départemental du conseil général la
question était supprimée ou pas des
aplats c'est justement parce qu'il nous
reste qu'une poignée de minutes j'ai
envie de vous demander on sait qu'il va
y avoir des très grandes régions partir
de décembre pour vous ça veut dire que
le département la place du département
elle est primordiale mais évidemment
contrairement à ce qui a été annoncé
pendant des mois effectivement par ce
gouvernement avec ces très grandes
régions on peut constater finalement que
le département doit prendre une place
plus importante sur la proximité et si
effectivement la population n'a plus ses
élus de proximité mais vous verrez que
la colère c'est encore beaucoup plus
importante ça serait on franchit encore
une étape supplémentaire et puis même
pour régler les problèmes de tous les
jours on parlait des collèges ont parlé
apparemment nous on nous passe les
transports au niveau de la région mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire est que la
population quand il veut en venir nous
voir nous élus de proximité avec des
problématiques de transport et on va
leur dire allez à belfort ou à besançon
parce qu'on sait même pas où est la
suivante à la capte un
ami de la semaine et vous acquiescez sur
normes importance de ce niveau n'est sûr
mais le gouvernement fait preuve de
pragmatisme et d'intelligence puisque
finalement il mettait les départements
mais en substance une question qui se
pose en france on a un millefeuille de
collectivités locales et on peut pas en
faire abstraction on a des doublons on a
des financements croisés donc à un
moment donné dans une période où il faut
faire des économies alors je dis plutôt
que d'être dans la posture de critiquer
qu'est ce qu'on propose en face c'est
pas une mince affaire de réformer le
pays on le sait très bien ce qu'il
suffit qu'ils aient comblé in pour
qu'ils y ait du monde dans les rues pour
protester pour contester donc c'est vrai
que il s'est peut-être qualifié de
mesurettes mais en tout cas quand on
additionne les mesurettes ça permet
d'avoir des vraies mesures et j'ai
tendance à dire que malheureusement ce
qui fait monter aussi le front national
c'est que le temps des habitants n'est
pas le temps des politiques et que les
habitants ils sont dans l'immédiateté
event du résultat tout de suite et
maintenant alors que les réformes pour
qu'elle puisse vraiment produire les
effets escomptés ça prend un peu de
temps et il est là elle est là la
dichotomie il est là l'écart entre le
temps du politique et le temps de
l'habitant mais c'est vrai que je pense
qu'on a plutôt intérêt à maintenir les
lieux de proximité qu'elle conseil
départemental qui est très pragmatique
qui hélas par rapport à des enjeux liés
au quotidien des habitants les gens ce
qu'ils veulent simplement faut être un
peu basique c'est qu'on s'occupe d'eux
au delà des débats nationaux qu'on
s'occupe d'eux tout simplement après
sans promettre évidemment tout et
n'importe quoi mais qu'on s'occupe d'eux
et je pense que c'est plutôt bon signe
de maintenir le conseil départemental
vous êtes concerné atlanthal de la
nièvre c'est très loin de dijon est très
loin de la franchise je confirme il
faut pour vous une facette proximité
importante ah bah oui oui c'est
essentiel enfin et encore plus avec une
grande région fun région élargie ainsi
il n'y a pas cet échelon là encore une
fois sur un territoire comme le
département de la nièvre qui est
essentiellement rural même si on a des
villes et des grandes villes mais bon
voilà c'est pas et il est enfin c'est
inimaginable de faire sans ce à quoi
comment vont faire les populations et en
dehors des populations des habitants
c'est comment vont faire aussi les
communes les communautés de communes sur
nos territoires on a des petites
communautés commune quand même un avec
un nombre d'habitants réduit donc
l'interlocuteur et les cardons qu'on est
en train d'étrangler actuellement oui
allez je vous coupe vous empêche de
débattre là dessus parce que je veux
juste nous lancer sur une prochaine
émission du 18 avril qui se posera la
question de la capitale la grande région
bourgogne franche comté
voilà ah non on va partir je vous
demande votre avis paris dijon besançon
mais vers les candidats devaient
réaliser la sony s'est faite
polichinelle chez un petit peu chemin
donc dijon dijon
les autres légendes viols sont très très
pro dijon on vous dira on est on est
quand même plus proche de la région
parisienne mais bonjour la capitale pour
la capitale dix jours voilà j'espère que
la maxime loin des yeux loin du coeur ne
va pas être une réalité il faudra pas
en amoureux dans la cahute dijon
besançon à paray-le-monial c'est pas mal
non
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu nous
raconter vos élections départementales
et puisqu'on parle de régionale samedi
prochain c'est alain joyandet le
sénateur ump franc comtois qui est
candidat aux régionales qui sera sur ce
plateau merci bon vitesse il bon retour
à ceux qui viennent de loin au revoir et
merci encore
et